There are myths of creativity and these
myths are usually propagated by people
that have romantic notions about heroes,
romantic notions about Eureka moments.
And these myths of creativity keep
people from collaborating and it causes
them to be a lone wolf and the research
says it causes them to fail.
So let me talk a little bit about those
myths of creativity.
In the world of sales and marketing,
I battle against three myths.
Myth number one,
the lone inventor.
This is very dangerous because there is
no such thing as alone in venture.
As a matter of fact,
there's a lot of historical research
that has debunked.
Einstein,
uh,
specifically in terms of inventions.
Henry Ford,
not a lone inventor.
Um,
classic example,
Thomas Edison in the invention
community.
Thomas Edison is a brand.
It stands for 14 people.
Yes,
there was a figure head named Thomas
Edison.
His name's on 10,000 patents.
He did not invent a single thing.
He marshaled people together and knew
how to spot innovations and put people
together.
Lack of a creative soup,
if you will.
Here's a classic example.
A Steve Jobs.
You know,
you ask the average person,
say a millennial who uses a lot of apple
technology,
who's one of the greatest inventors of
our time?
They'll say,
Steve Jobs.
Steve jobs once said,
I never created anything.
All I did was notice patterns.
It put people together to finish
projects,
so think about it.
If he doesn't have Wazniak,
there is no original apple,
right?
If he doesn't have eyes,
there is no ipod.
If he doesn't have Tony Fidel,
there is no iphone and the list goes on
and on.
Got a good friend of mine,
David Berkus.
He wrote a really wonderful book,
the about about the myths of,
of genius and he was telling me that
it's a romantic notion and I remember
when I first read this research years
ago,
no lone inventor,
it did kind of hurt my feelings.
I'm the musician.
In my past I thought I wrote a lot of
songs,
but according to the research,
I didn't never wrote a song.
I always collaborated with somebody.
The song that actually made it to the
record and made it on the radio,
had 15 to 50 hands on it.
When I talked to David,
I said,
when I read your research kind of hurt
my feelings.
He goes,
it's a romantic notion because we want
to be heroes.
We want to be as empowered as I then
ran.
We want to think that we're the
fountainhead.
So this is how we tell the story.
But until you believe that genius is a
team sport,
you will never give up control.
And this is the problem for a lot of
people in sales.
Um,
they don't want to seed any level of
control over their process to somebody
outside of sales world because they
don't value those voices enough.
But the research is clear on this.
Miller Heiman Institute research the
difference between good and great.
They call it world class organizations.
They,
when they 20% more than their nearest
competitor,
the only thing they have in common is
they've broken this myth and they
understand that every deal is about
rapid problem solving and no one person
can solve the problem on their own
quickly.
The other two myths of creativity that
must be dispelled is the Eureka moment.
There is no such thing as a big idea
that changes the world.
I know this is another one of those
hurtful but very true based on empirical
research points.
There are little ideas that combine with
other little ideas that improve
themselves into game changing ideas.
And I've experienced this personally,
but who I consider a one of the
authorities on creativity.
Um,
ed catmull,
president of Pixar,
I remember standing backstage a few
years ago just gushing to him about John
Lasseter.
I'm like,
John Lasseter,
his vp of creative.
I'm like,
he's the bomb.
This is the guy who wrote wally the
commercial.
This is the guy that wrote the script
for toy story.
You know,
telling the story from the toys point of
view and that remember catmull looked at
me,
cut me off,
and not to dismiss lassiner he said toy
story was a problematic idea from the
start.
Make an entire full length feature film
inside a computer.
Do you understand how hard that is from
a rendering time standpoint?
Make the characters as human as human.
They didn't even have facial controller
technology at the time for this and tell
the story from the toys point of view,
when we've never historically had a toy,
I have any narrative for us to draw on.
Gaton will explain that.
Nine months in,
they shut the film down after a meeting
with Disney,
they called it black Friday and then cat
moe said something to me that shattered
the myth of the Eureka moment.
Capital said toy story.
The movie you saw was a thousand
problems solved and it was like it was
like a bolt of lightning.
I was like,
I get it.
When you do a million dollar deal and an
ad agency,
it's not a big idea.
It's a hundred problems solved.
80 of them are inside your agency.
As you move through every level of that
sale,
you get obstacles in front of you and
what this means is that if we no longer
depend on the big idea to fall out of
the sky and change the world,
we meet more.
We think more,
we research more,
we subtle with small pieces of progress
that add up to momentum.
Finally,
the third myth of genius or creativity
that must be shattered if you want to be
more collaborative,
is the myth of the expert.
Now,
I believe in involving people in a deal,
strom,
who we think are experts on the problem
space.
But if you notice,
I don't want experts on the solution
space because most of the great
solutions to vexing problems come from
the edges of a domain.
You know people that don't know what
they don't know,
so they're not limited by these false
constraints that hold people back that
are in the middle of this subject.
So the way I like to think about it is
if you could talk to a fish,
if you could,
if the fish could respond,
if it could,
and you walked up to a fish in a fish
bowl and you asked the fish,
how's the water?
The fish would look at you puzzled and
ask you what's water?
And that's the problem with experts.
People that are so steeped in a domain,
they don't have the expansive
perspective that allows them to
recognize patterns and convergence.
Because every invention,
every solution is really about pattern
or convergence recognition and so it's
really important for us to follow the
following mantra and collaboration.
Ideas can come from anywhere.
As a matter of fact,
in dealstorming that is one of my four
key ground rules.
It's just as important as stay on agenda
and don't distract the person next to
you because the problem with the myth of
expert is it leads to not invented here
dismissal of good ideas.
So when you're in a deal store meeting
and someone who's on the edge of the
domain,
I'll just give you an example.
Someone out of finance that generally
handles something as mundane as revenue
recognition.
They come to one of your meetings
because you have a problem related to
how you recognize their revenue of this
deal or whatever and you're in the
middle of this conversation about
packaging and they come up with a really
novel way to think about how it's built.
You might look at that person and say,
you don't know anything about billing
sales.
You're just a revenue recognition
analyst.
We know billing and sales,
you're about to shut him down for the
rest of the meeting.
And what you don't understand is that he
may have an educational background.
He may have had previous jobs,
he may have a significant other that is
steeped in the billing expertise,
and he's drawing upon all that.
The minute you tell someone,
only experts can weigh in with ideas.
Everyone who's not an expert stops
contributing.
And in my experience,
it breaks down collaboration.